welcome back so where I left off I was
hopefully trying to give you an
intuition of this this inward
acceleration in this case I have a rock
spinning around and I'm holding it on a
string and I want to think about what
the xcel the inward acceleration is
dependent on and so we talked a little
bit about its velocity and these these
multiple red arrows these are potential
velocity vectors and what I was the
point I was trying to make is if the
velocity vector is bigger right to
change its direction requires even more
acceleration right because the change in
the X Direction is bigger and then the
change in the Y Direction is bigger
because for example right here it's why
its Y velocity I'll draw it in a
different color it's Y velocity vector
and I'll do it for the big velocity its
Y velocity vector was here and then now
it's Y velocity vector is this all
almost essentially the whole vector
right so when the velocity increment
let's say so this is the case of the big
the big error if the velocity was less
like the small arrow it's velocity
vector would was here and it would have
to go to here and so I don't know if
it's completely obvious but the change
in velocity for example in the Y
Direction over this course of time has
to be more and likewise the change in X
Direction over this and that might be
obvious more obvious because here this
is the X velocity vector for the if the
velocity was less and this is the X
velocity vector if it was more and
that's going to zero between when the
dot goes from here to here here it has
no X component right so clearly I would
have had to decelerate in the X
Direction more if we have a larger
velocity vector I'm either giving you
intuition or I'm confusing you but I'll
keep going so velocity clearly the
greater the velocity the more I'm going
to have to pull in on this on this the
more the inward acceleration has to be
to kind of keep this thing going in a
circle and not only does the
acceleration have to be bigger just to
get that velocity vector down but you
got to realize when between this point
between this point and this point the
faster I go the less time is going to
take me to get from here to here right
so not only am I going to have to change
the velocity more
I have to do that in less time so it's
kind of the velocity is affecting this
acceleration that I need to pull it in
two ways so the higher the velocity I
have to change more velocity they have
to do it in less time and it actually
turns out that the acceleration is
proportional to the velocity squared and
then there's another term here and I
won't prove it in this video I'm going
to prove it in another video that might
be out of your scope just now because it
requires some calculus but I want to
give you an intuition so we know that
the plot the acceleration is dependent
on the velocity squared
and I want to make that point of why
it's not just the velocity because
there's two ways that the velocity is
affecting the that is affecting how much
of acceleration I need one is just the
magnitude of the velocity the more that
is the more I have to accelerate to
change its direction and the second is
between this point and this point I have
less time to change that velocity so the
velocity affects it in two ways and
that's where you get an intuition for
the V squared the other thing that
matters is actually the radius so let's
say that this is this is the radius and
the acceleration is inversely
proportional to the radius and why is
that
what's kind of like the second I guess
we could call it velocity argument I
gave the bigger the radius so let's say
that let's let's look at this radius and
let's look at another radius that is
bigger let's say that this is another
radius let's say if the string was
longer and that this was another case
let's say this is a case but the
velocity was the same so this is just a
case with a larger rate whoops so that's
the let's say it's the same velocity
vector so we have the same thing at play
to go from there to say there we have to
change the velocity the same magnitude
right as we had to go to change the
velocity from here to here but one thing
changes this distance is longer right so
this velocity is the same as this
velocity but this distance is longer you
have more time to change the velocity
so the larger the radius the more time
you have to change the velocity and so
the less acceleration you need hopefully
that makes sense I don't know if it if
it completely let me let me let me
repeat it just because it's it I think
it's nice to have the intuition between
this point and this point on let's say
when you have a smaller radius if I want
to change the acceleration whoops the
acceleration vector from that to that I
have however long it takes to go this
distance I have that long to change its
acceleration vector it's velocity vector
but if the radius was a little longer
and I had the same velocity so here the
velocities that and then here the
velocity is that I have a little bit
more time to change its velocity and
remember acceleration is just change in
velocity over change in time and so if I
have the same change in velocity but I
have more time to do it with so if this
is a bigger number the required
acceleration is less so maybe I've given
you intuition and I will prove this for
sure because this was kind of a very
touchy this is very kind of soft way and
and not not very rigorous way of proving
that the required acceleration to make
something go in a circle is V squared
over R but except that is a bit of faith
and I'll prove it especially once you
learn your calculus and you can watch
that video and we could do a couple of
problems and this is probably what you
care about anyway but I think it's nice
to have that intuition so once again
let's let's say we're in well let's
let's let's say we're we're in deep
space well let's say let's let's do a
little orbit problem let's say that this
is Earth I will do earth in blue let's
say that that is Earth and I have a
satellite that is going around earth and
I'm not going to calculate it's this is
a satellite that's going around earth
and we're I'm going to do a whole other
video on actually figuring out the the
gravitational force depending on how far
away you are from an object but let's
just assume that it's gravitational
force is similar to what it is on the
surface of Earth and that is a big
assumption or let's just assume this is
a different planet I'm going to give you
it's the gravitational acceleration
let's say that the the planet and maybe
this isn't Earth is pulling inwards
right it always pulls towards its center
and I'll do that in a different color
let's say it's pulling inwards at 30
feet per second my question is what does
the velocity of the satellite have to be
for the object to stay in orbit well
that we could just apply the formula and
then maybe we can have a little
intuition so acceleration is equal to V
o and sorry and let's say that the
object is let's say the object is I
don't know 6,000 feet 6000 feet from the
center and and when we learn gravity
we'll learn it actually the it's it's
the distance from the the radius that
you're going around is actually relative
to the center well actually it's always
going to be right because this is the
circle right so the radius if this is
the center of that circle you have to
worry about that
that's nothing to do with gravity okay
so the acceleration is V squared over R
the acceleration we know is 30 feet per
second we want to figure out the
velocity and then the radius I said is
6,000 feet 6,000 feet so let's let's
ignore the units for now this complex
complex so multiply both sides this
equation times 6,000 so 3 times 6 is 18
in left 4 0 2 3 4 so V squared is equal
to 18,000 everything's in feet per
second and so what's V so V is equal to
the square root of 180,000 let me get
the calculator out because I haven't
memorized my perfect my squares that I 1
2 3 take the square root so 424
so the required velocity is 424 feet per
second so if this satellite is at that
velocity it will go in perfect orbit
around this planet now what happens if
if the object's velocity is I don't know
let's say it's a little slower let's say
the eight let's what happens let me do
it in different colors you know what I'm
talking about
what happens if its velocity is a little
bit less than that let's say its
velocity is 300 feet per second well
then it's not going to be able to travel
far enough tangent to the circle to
before well the way that it'll
essentially just do this it'll always be
getting a little bit closer and it will
spiral in and it'll hit the planet and
the way to think about this another way
to think about what the required
velocity is you have to go fast enough
so that you're always falling in but
every time you fall in you want to go in
this case to the right enough so that
you're an equal distant oh you're still
the same distance away from the center
so that your distance from the center
never changes if you're going fast
enough
and then what happens if its velocity is
too fast what happens in the case where
it's velocity is I don't know 600 feet
per second 600 feet per second well in
that case the object will have enough
velocity to actually escape the orbit of
the planet but anyway that's enough
about that I actually out of time so
I'll see you the next video